[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you know there is something about that  tangle of strangers press to the other  four days with nothing in common but  they need to go from one place to  another and never see each other again I  see evil on this train  a passenger has died so they got him  after all  you asked him you're skint no no no no  not well it was in perfectly good health  he had his enemies indeed he was another  God murder here God rest his soul  someone was rummaging around my cabin in  the middle of the night no one would  listen to me if there was a murder what  is going on and there was a murderer  the murderer is with us and every one of  you is a suspect and who are you my name  is lq PAHO and I'm probably the greatest  detective in the world  [Music]